[Music]
chernobyl is synonymous with danger
driving into the north ukrainian city
we're warned to keep our windows shut
radiation levels in some spots remain
dangerously high 36 years since the
world's worst nuclear plant disaster
engineer alexander skereta and his
colleagues are responsible for
maintaining the area around the
notorious nuclear plant they're only
permitted to live here 15 days per month
to limit their exposure which makes the
russian military's actions here
difficult to comprehend
the whole world knows about chernobyl he
says
i can't understand the russian brain
what were they thinking after the
russian retreat skereta returned to work
to find this his office like so many
others here ransacked and looted his
computer among the thousands of pieces
of highly sensitive and expensive
equipment either stolen or destroyed
they made a mess of everything he says
chernobyl sits a short drive from the
belarus border and was quickly captured
by russian troops on the first day of
the invasion
this resident says the russians caught
her trying to contact ukrainian
authorities
they forced me to my knees with a gun to
my head she says i thought i was going
to die when the russians finally left
after five weeks she says they strapped
washing machines and other household
appliances to the tops of their tanks
but the greatest damage done by russian
soldiers here might have actually been
to themselves this is the edge of the
so-called red forest in chernobyl and it
has that name because a lot of evergreen
trees here have turned a shade of
reddish orange as a result of the high
level of radiation that exists on the
soil we're only being allowed to visit
here for a few minutes but it seems the
russians stayed here for a few weeks not
only in the red forest but digging
trenches in the soil there are food
containers scattered all around here
they even used some of the sand
to make sandbags
you have to be crazy or stupid to do
that kind of thing do they have a death
wish ask this member of ukraine's
national guard he showed us numerous
examples where the russians trampled
bulldozed and dug up one of the most
toxic places on earth possibly inhaling
the dangerous dust
our informants in belarus told us that
some of the russian soldiers who stayed
in those trenches were later
hospitalized he says ukraine's nuclear
scientists say radiation levels at the
chernobyl site are now safe but the
russian activity disrupted enough soil
to create additional radiation hot spots
the worst case scenario once feared was
avoided but more than two months since
russian troops left this area crews have
barely begun to clean up their mess jeff
semple global news chernobyl